dignity does not consist in possessing
honors but in deserving them
[Music]
education is an ornament in prosperity
and a refuge in adversity
courage is the first of human qualities
because it is the quality that
guarantees the others
[Music]
democracy is when the indigent not men
of property are the rulers
good habits formed in youth make all the
difference
to write well express yourself like
common people but think like a wise man
or think as wise men do
but speak as common people do
it is the mark of an educated mind to be
able to entertain a thought without
accepting it
educating the mind without educating the
heart is no education at all
[Music]
the energy of the mind is the essence of
life
[Music]
through discipline
comes freedom
[Music]
the best choice for each individual is
the highest it is possible for him to
achieve
all persons ought to endeavor to follow
what is right and not what is
established
friendship is essentially a partnership
[Music]
criticism is something we can avoid
easily by saying nothing doing nothing
and being nothing
prt requires us to honor truth above our
friends
[Music]
quality is not an act it is a habit
[Music]
wise men speak when they have something
to say
fools speak when they have to say
something
[Music]
he who has overcome his fears will truly
be free
patience is bitter but its fruit is
sweet
the educated differ from the uneducated
as much as the living from the dead
pleasure in the job puts perfection in
the work
character may almost be called the most
effective means of persuasion
happiness is an expression of the soul
inconsidered actions
[Music]
hope is a waking dream
[Music]
it is well to be up before daybreak for
such habits contribute to health wealth
and wisdom
men create gods after their own image
not only with regard to their form but
with regard to their mode of life
it is during our darkest moments that we
must focus to see the light
it is easy to perform a good action but
not easy to acquire a settled habit of
performing such actions
where your talents and the needs of the
world cross there lies your vocation
[Music]
knowing yourself is the beginning of all
wisdom
poverty is the parent of revolution and
crime
those who educate children well
are more to be honored than those who
produce them
for the latter only give them life
the former give them the art of living
well
happiness depends on ourselves
at his best man is the noblest of all
animals separated from law and justice
he is at his worst
obstinate people can be divided into the
opinionated the ignorant and the boorish
the only exclusive sign of thorough
knowledge is the power of teaching
change in all things is sweet
[Music]
the antidote for 50 enemies is one
friend
[Music]
fear is pain arising from the
anticipation of evil
[Music]
the actuality of thought is life
wishing to be friends is quick work
but friendship is a slow ripening fruit
[Music]
democracy arose for men's thinking that
if they are equal in any respect
they are equal absolutely
[Music]
the worst form of inequality is to try
to make unequal things equal
whatever lies within our power to do
lies also within our power not to do
[Music]
the ideal man bears the accidents of
life with dignity and grace
making the best of circumstances
[Music]
education is the best provision for old
age
man is a goal seeking animal
his life only has meaning if he is
striving for his goals
a friend to all is a friend to none
it is not always the same thing to be a
good man and a good citizen
the aim of art is to represent not the
outward appearance of things but their
inward significance
a likely impossibility is always
preferable to an unconvincing
possibility
all human actions have one or more of
these seven causes
chance
nature
compulsions habit
reason
passion
desire
he who has never learned to obey cannot
be a good commander
[Music]
the most perfect political community is
one in which the middle class is in
control
and outnumbers both of the other classes
[Music]
the aim of the wise is not to secure
pleasure but to avoid pain
for the things we have to learn before
we can do them
we learn by doing them
the secret of humor is surprise
we give up leisure in order that we may
have leisure
just as we go to war in order that we
may have peace
wicked men obey from fear
good men from love
wit is educated insolence
[Music]
all human beings by nature desire to
know
moral excellence comes about as a result
of habit
we become just by doing just acts temper
it by doing temper dax brave by doing
brave acts
my best friend is the man who in wishing
me well
wishes it for my sake
whosoever is delighted in solitude is
either a wild beast or a god
great men are always of a nature
originally melancholy
[Music]
you will never do anything in the world
without courage
it is the greatest quality of the mind
next to honor
the ideal age for marriage in men is 35.
the ideal age for marriage and women is
18.
[Music]
we live in deeds not years in thoughts
not breaths in feelings not in figures
on a dial
we should count time by heartthrobs
[Music]
he most lives who thinks most feels the
noblest acts the best
[Music]
you